yes you read that title correctly stop
take your finger off the add to cart
button on the ipad pro
on amazon because you're about to make a
huge
mistake so let me explain why as most of
you know there have been a lot of leaks
and rumors over the past months
about apple working on their next ipad
pro refresh
way back in june the very reliable
leaker love to dream
claimed that a revamped mini led display
and 5g connectivity are coming to the
ipad pro
sometime in the first half of 2021.
these are both
very huge features especially the
display
since it's been mostly unchanged for
years using basically the same lcd panel
technology
since i can remember so a switch to
melee led is going to be amazing
and of course 5g is going to be a really
big deal
for those who want to turn their ipad
into a mobile workstation
no matter where they are and ever since
that tweet from love to dream
we've been seeing more and more leaks
and rumors pointing to it releasing at
apple's annual march event
a couple of months back someone asked
john prosser when the next ipad pro will
be released
and he said march and then we also got
some leaked cad files
of the ipad pro's final design pointed
to being very close to its official
release date
and by the way these include an 11 inch
size
model as well which confirms that we'll
be getting both
an 11 and a 12.9 inch ipad pro
contrary to my previous thoughts that
apple could potentially discontinue it
now the reason that i thought that is
because there were a lot of leaks and
rumors back then
that mentioned only the 12.9 inch model
which is really weird but now it's
making a bit more sense
with rumors pointing to the mini led
display exclusively going to the 12.9
inch ipad pro model
while the 11 inch sticks with lcd
now moving on we've been getting a lot
of rumors surrounding the date of
apple's march event
like when just a couple of weeks ago
kong the most reliable apple leaker out
there
said that the apple event will be hosted
on march
23rd john prosser then agreed with that
date
also adding in a few apple products that
he expects to get released at the event
namely the air tags ipad pro airpods
and the apple tv now here is where it
gets
really weird in previous years apple
always sent out invitations for their
march events
quite a bit early like in 2019 they sent
it out 14 days before the event
in 2018 they sent it out 11 days earlier
in 2016 11 days earlier again
and as for wwdc last year the invitation
was sent out
seven days earlier in 2019 12 days
in 2018 13 days and as for their iphone
event
invitations were always sent out at
least
a full week before the actual event took
place
the point that i'm trying to make is
that apple has never announced an event
digital or non-digital less than a week
before the actual event so if apple was
hosting a march event on the 23rd
which is a tuesday the most common day
for apple events
then they would have sent out the
invitations yesterday morning
but they didn't so yeah guys no apple
event this month
and because of that john prosser has to
shave his eyebrows
because he said he was 100 sure it would
happen
and if it didn't he would shave them and
now he's saying that it's going to
happen
in april so i guess apple had some sort
of delay
that came out at the last minute since
it shows that kong also got it wrong
but despite that you should still
definitely wait to buy an ipad pro
even if it's coming next month because i
think this new one
is going to be great for a few different
reasons last month
mark german claimed that the chip going
into the ipad pro
which we think is going to be the a14x
is gonna have performance on par with
the m1 chip
in the latest max this is just
insane because as you know the m1 max
are incredibly powerful
compared to a lot of other computers out
there
so having that power built into an ipad
pro
is incredible but really what mark is
trying to say
is that the a14x chip will likely have
the same eight core cpu
and eight core gpu set up as the m1 chip
but without all the extra components
that's meant for mac related stuff
this is a really big deal because last
year's ipad pro update
didn't really come with a major cpu
improvement
the a12z chip was literally identical to
the a12x from 2018
apart from adding one extra graphics
core so the a14x ipad pro
is going to be game changing and i
honestly don't think
any other tablet ever will get anywhere
near the ipad pro's performance
now as far as the design the leaked cad
files show that it's going to look
basically the same with very minor
changes if any at all
now i know people are expecting a bit
more from apple
but i personally think that the huge
boost in performance
combined with much faster lte speeds
thanks to the new 5g modems and of
course 5g
and the new mini led display are all
going to be
enough of a reason for many people to
upgrade
but don't worry i think apple has
something else up their sleeve
that's going to make the ipad pro a
whole lot more useful
yes i think that apple is going to be
coming out with a new magic keyboard
case
for the ipad pro and the ipad air 4. and
it's actually going to be
pretty great way back in august of last
year comia on twitter
claimed that a new magic keyboard is
planned for march 2021
and when asked about the price he said
it'll be the same
299 dollars as it currently is and if
you're wondering how it could be
different from the original
apple actually filed for a patent almost
a full year ago
with some pretty significant changes
first off there's a slot in the hinge
which holds the apple pencil 2 which is
basically a dream come true
for an ipad pro case and to make it even
better
the patent says that the slot also
wirelessly charges the apple pencil
at the same time making it the perfect
solution since right now with the
current magic keyboard the pencil is
basically exposed all the time
now getting into the next patent image
it shows a completely new hinge
system essentially allowing you to raise
the ipad pro
much higher if you'd like to or even use
it in a new
clipboard mode which will finally solve
the problem people had with the other
magic keyboard
where you couldn't lay the ipad pro down
to write and draw
so if apple is truly releasing a new
magic keyboard along the new ipad pro
this month then that would really help
it become a more useful device
but it doesn't stop there because i
think apple has even more tricks up
their sleeve
meant for the ipad pro so let's get
right into those
if you think about it the current ipad
pro is already
extremely powerful being faster than
any other tablet out there so if the
a14x chip in the new ipad pro coming
this month
is going to be as powerful as mark
german says it'll be
how in the world are we going to take
advantage of that power
well almost a full year ago john prosser
tweeted
that he is 100 confident that final cut
pro
logic pro and xcode are coming to the
ipad pro
those are all professional mac
applications that we actually
tested and benchmarked using the m1 max
and the performance was killer so it's
looking like you'll be able to buy
an ipad pro and do this type of
professional work
without ever needing a mac now some of
you might say that it doesn't make sense
for apple to do this
because less people are going to be
buying the more expensive
macbooks but on the other hand support
for these mac
apps is going to really help push sales
of the magic keyboard case
which is priced at 300 since it's going
to help you make the most out of those
apps
and as far as the release timeline for
those mac apps
they could either release them alongside
the new ipad pro
or they could wait until the wwdc
conference in
june since that mostly focuses on
software
so basically if you put all of those
puzzle pieces together
it totally makes sense for apple to
release a new ipad pro
sometime next month at their april event
which is
a first timer alongside an updated magic
keyboard case
now if you totally disagree with me go
ahead and comment your thoughts down in
the comment section below
but if you enjoyed it click that circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]